qui est roland garros eh bien ce n'est
pas un tennisman c'est un navigateur
français il est né à saint denis de la
réunion le 6 octobre 1888 combes 1909 il
assiste pour la première fois un meeting
aérien il est fasciné par ces machines
volantes il s'achète un avion apprend
seul à piloter et passe son brevet deux
ans plus tard en 1911 il bat le record
d'altitude à 3910 m il va encore plus
loin et décide de traverser la
méditerranée
une première malgré deux panne en plein
vol il réussit l'exploit et s'oppose à
tunisie la guerre éclate il s'engage il
va marquer son époque en mettant au
point le premier avion monoplace dotée
d'une mitrailleuse majid ses talents de
pilote en langue arrow sera abattu en
octobre 1918 lors d'un combat
quelques semaines seulement avant
l'armistice pour honorer sa bravoure et
sa mémoire son nom sera donné au célèbre
stade de tennis